El vaticano es uno de los estados más
jóvenes del mundo. Tal cual como lo oís.
Fue creado en el año 1929 tras la firma
de los acuerdos de Letrán.
Sin embargo la diplomacia papal es la
más antigua del mundo y os
preguntaréis ¿cómo es esto posible?
Lo cierto es que tenemos que distinguir
entre dos conceptos: por un lado está la
ciudad del vaticano que es un estado
independiente y soberano y por el otro
está lo que llamamos la santa sede
que es el gobierno de la iglesia
católica. Es decir que como estado
nación
el vaticano es el país más pequeño
del mundo, ni siquiera tiene
representación en las naciones unidas.
Ahora bien, la santa sede es una de las
instituciones más importantes del
planeta con influencias sobre más de
1.200 millones de católicos repartidos
por todo el mundo
y precisamente por esto la diplomacia
papal es tan importante.
Es más el vaticano tiene
representación en prácticamente todos
los estados del mundo.
Bueno en realidad en  todos no, hay algunas
excepciones, principalmente la república
popular de china. Y quedaros con esto
porque va a ser muy importante a lo
largo del vídeo. Como sabéis los papás
siempre se han caracterizado por tener
un lenguaje muy moderado, evitando hacer
acusaciones o ataques personales. Incluso
hoy en día cuando el papá francisco
quiere criticar a Donald Trump lo
hace evitando mencionar su nombre.
Por eso cuando hablamos del vaticano lo
más importante son los pequeños
detalles, por ejemplo con quien se reúne
el papa o con quien no se reúne.
Y precisamente por eso esta noticia es tan
significativa: el Papa Francisco rechaza
al Dalai Lama en la gala de los nobel de
la paz.
El pontífice que intenta mejorar las
relaciones con otras religiones decide
no reunirse con el líder del budismo
tibetano por miedo a irritar a Pekín.
Y os preguntaréis: si hemos dicho que
la santa sede no tiene relaciones con
china
¿a qué se debe este repentino interés
del papa francisco por mejorar sus
relaciones con pekín?
Hoy vamos a responder a esa pregunta y
además atentos porque al final del
vídeo
tengo una sorpresa para todos vosotros.
Pero antes vamos a ver un poco de
historia.
Los que estáis suscritos a VisualPolitik
desde hace tiempo
conocéis muy bien el sistema político
chino y seguramente reconoceréis a
este hombre que aparece en pantalla:
Mao Tse Tung.
Mao es el padre de la revolución
comunista china y un hombre al que no le
gustaban las medias tintas.
Durante su gobierno todos aquellos que
no seguían al pie de la letra las
directrices del partido comunista chino
eran perseguidos y por supuesto esto
incluye a los católicos cuyo lider
supremo,
independientemente del país en el que
estén, es el Papa de Roma.
Sin embargo, ya sabéis que en China
todas las cifras son descomunales: en
la época de mao había más de seis
millones de católicos en ese país y
era prácticamente imposible acabar con
ellos.
Todavía hoy en china quedan aldeas
con muchos cristianos ¿Cómo y por qué
aguanta esta gente pese a la revolución
cultural de Mao?
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué hizo
Mao para acabar con los católicos ¿los
exterminó? ¿los expulsó del país?
Nada de eso, en un alarde de inteligencia
el partido comunista inventó su propia
versión del catolicismo una iglesia
católica made in china compatible con
los principios y la ideología de
Mao Tse Tung.
Así es como en 1957 nace la
Asociación de Católicos Patriotas Chinos,
una réplica de la iglesia católica con
su catecismo, sus misas, sus sacerdotes...
Pero con una diferencia sustancial:
en esta asociación los obispos no los
nombra el vaticano sino el partido
comunista chino. Como es podéis imaginar
la santa sede no reconoce esta
iglesia y la considera una herejía.
Es más, durante décadas todos los papas
han presionado a Pekín para que les
permita ordenar a los obispos chinos.
Y como no se ponían de acuerdo China
prohíbe al vaticano establecer
embajadas en su territorio. Mientras
tanto la mayor parte de los católicos
chinos pertenecen a esta asociación.
Pero esperad un momento porque hay una minoría que
todavía obedece las órdenes del obispo
de roma y como os podéis imaginar no
tienen una vida fácil.
Por cierto, que esto tan bonito que está sonando es
la música de Tasmania un grupo de rock
de españa que nos ha enviado su maqueta.
Si os gusta encontrareis más
información en los enlaces de la
descripción.
Estamos hablando de tráfico de órganos.
Por ejemplo, imaginad que tenéis una
enfermedad muy grave en los riñones y
necesitáis que os hagan un trasplante.
Encontrar un donante es muy difícil, en
la mayor parte de los casos se recurre a
un familiar: un padre, un hermano, un
hijo que se presten voluntariamente a
donar su riñón.
Como sabéis una persona puede hacer una
vida normal con un solo riñón o
después de haber dado parte del hígado.
Pero sin embargo hay órganos vitales
como los pulmones, el corazón o el
páncreas que sólo se pueden donar
después de haber muerto. Por supuesto
tanto en Estados Unidos como en Europa
como en todos los países de
latinoamérica está terminantemente
prohibido vender tus órganos o que
te los extirpen sin su permiso y todo esto hace
que los órganos listos para trasplantar
sean un bien escaso y ¿qué pasa con los
bienes escasos? Pues que su precio en el
mercado negro se pone por las nubes.
Para que os hagáis una idea, según
estimaciones un corazón puede llegar
a costar más de 130 mil dólares.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Quién puede estar
tan desesperado como para vender sus
órganos en el mercado negro?
Muchos pensaréis que hay gente en una
situación tan precaria que está
dispuesta a que le asesinen
si con eso puede alimentar a su familia
pero en realidad la respuesta es mucho
peor que todo eso.
- "China continúa cosechando órganos de
prisioneros de forma masiva". De verdad
que estáis leyendo bien y quedaros con
la palabra continua porque lo cierto es
que las acusaciones de cosecha de
órganos hacia el partido comunista chino
datan desde hace seis décadas. Y os
preguntaréis ¿qué es la cosecha de
órganos? Pues simplemente, el gobierno
chino tiene fichas médicas de todos
sus presos,
especialmente los disidentes políticos.
Cada vez que un hospital chino necesita
hacer un trasplante de órganos
da igual que sea un corazón, un riñón
un páncreas o un pulmón cogen a uno de
estos convictos y se lo extirpan por
su supuesto sin su consentimiento.
Eso explica que China sea el segundo país
que más trasplantes de órganos
realiza pese a que apenas tienen gente
registrada como donantes voluntarios.
"En cualquier parte del mundo hay que
esperar meses o incluso años para hacer
un trasplante
en China lo consigues en días". Según las
estimaciones sólo en China se venden más
de 11.000 órganos al año,
principalmente de riñón.
Como os podéis imaginar estos
católicos que no pertenecen a la
asociación de católicos patriotas chinos
son susceptibles de que en
cualquier momento les extirpen cualquiera
de sus órganos para algún
trasplante. Pero ojo porque no son los
únicos: en esa lista tendríamos que
incluir también a los seguidores del
Dalai lama o a todos aquellos que
practiquen alguna religión  no
aceptada por el gobierno.
Por  supuesto tanto las
Naciones Unidas, como Estados Unidos , como
la Unión Europea están presionando al
gobierno chino para que termine con estas
prácticas y Pekín por su parte niega
todas las acusaciones y lleva años
enviando a propagandistas para que
defiendan el sistema de trasplantes chino
en la comunidad internacional.
Sin embargo, todas las evidencias
demuestran que china continúa
eliminando a presos políticos para
extirparles órganos.
Y ahora os preguntaréis todo esto ¿qué
tiene que ver con el Vaticano o La Santa
Sede? Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
¿Recordáis que os decía que la santa
sede no tiene ninguna relación con el
partido comunista chino? Pues esto era
cierto hasta el nombramiento del Papá
Francisco.
Es más, todos los anteriores pontífices
no tenían ningún problema en reunirse
con el Dalai Lama pese a que se
considera una ofensa diplomática contra
el gobierno chino.
Sin embargo, una de las principales
prioridades del Papa Francisco es lograr
que esta asociación de católicos patriotas chinos
permita que la Santa Sede
nombre a los obispos.
Y para eso necesita mejorar sus
relaciones con Pekín. Su primer gesto de
amistad con el gobierno chino fue su
negativa a recibir al dalai lama pero al
parecer eso no fue suficiente.
Así que en febrero de 2017 la curia
vaticana decidió dar un paso más y por
eso invitaron al doctor  Huang Jiefu
a participar en una cumbre pontífice
sobres el tráfico de órganos.
"En los últimos años el doctor
Huang ha estado viajando por todo el
mundo para convencer a todos de que el
sistema de trasplantes de órganos
chinos es bueno y que sólo emplea a
donantes voluntarios".
El problema es que todas las evidencias
demuestran lo contrario.
De hecho, esta es la primera vez que un
estado que no sea China invita a este
Dr. Huang Jeifu, doctor que para más inri
es cirujano experto en trasplantes. Así
que ya os podéis imaginar el triunfo que
esta conferencia ha supuesto para la
diplomacia china. Por fin una
institución tan influyente como la
iglesia católica le da carta de
naturaleza al sistema de trasplantes chino.
Y por cierto os recomiendo
encarecidamente que sigáis este canal
de youtube: China Uncensored, es una
de las mejores fuentes de información
que hay sobre política china.
Y algunos pensaréis que el Vaticano no
tenía ni idea de lo que estaba
ocurriendo ¿verdad? Pues lo cierto es que
habían recibido toda clase de avisos
antes de invitar a de invitar a este doctor Huang Jeifu
a dar la charla en el Vaticano.
Es más, esta fue la respuesta que dio
nada menos que el canciller de la
academia pontificia de las ciencias
monseñor marcelo Sánchez:
La conferencia fue un ejercicio académico
no una discusión sobre asuntos
políticos".
Mientras tanto el mismo Papá Francisco
ha presentado esta conferencia como un
paso más en la lucha contra el tráfico
de órganos.
Al mismo tiempo la Santa Sede se ha
convertido en la primera y única
institución internacional que ha
aceptado el sistema de trasplantes del
partido comunista chino.
De hecho esa es la noticia que publicaba
una de las agencias de noticias del
vaticano: "por ejemplo en China el gobierno
autorizaba en el pasado el uso de
órganos de los presos ejecutados, una
práctica que ya no realiza y cuya
prohibición aplaudió el Vaticano".
En fin, puede que el monseñor marcelo
sánchez tenga razón y esto sea
simplemente una cuestión académica
que no tienen nada que ver con la
política pero mirad que casualidad
justo en el mismo mes en el que el
vaticano invitó al doctor Huang Jeifu
a dar la charla aparece esta otra
noticia:
El Vaticano y Pekín llegan a un acuerdo en
la ordenación de arzobispos.
"Es una
reunión internacional muy importante
por la noble identidad del Papá Francisco.
Soy cirujano no sé nada de
diplomacia pero esta es una señal de
que los ciudadanos chinos queremos
mejorar nuestra relación con los
ciudadanos del Vaticano". Es decir, que el
Papá Francisco ha logrado lo que no fue
capaz de hacer ninguno de sus
predecesores: legalizar el catolicismo
en China. A cambio sólo ha tenido que
hacerles un pequeño favorcito con
el tema del tráfico de órganos y los
disidentes político.
Por supuesto que este acuerdo puede
salvar la vidas de muchos católicos
que ahora están perseguidos en China pero
no olvidéis que hay muchas otras
minorías que todavía siguen siendo
víctimas de esta cosecha de órganos.
Y es más, muchas de esas minorías ahora
están más desprotegidas que nunca
después de que el vaticano deje de
presionar a China.
Junio de 2016: China ha continuado cosechando órganos
de prisioneros a escala masiva. Según un
nuevo informe
los prisioneros de conciencia
especialmente los practicantes de falun
gong continúan siendo el objetivo
principal".
Mientras tanto el Papá Francisco
continúa dando lecciones morales a
políticos como Ángela Merkel o Barack
Obama. Al parecer le debe gustar más el
modo de gobierno del partido comunista
chino, sistema que por cierto es un
híbrido entre comunismo, capitalismo y
dictadura.
Si queréis entenderlo mejor haces clic
en este enlace para ver el video en el
que explicó todo lo que necesitas saber
sobre el sistema político chino.
Y vosotros ¿que pensáis? ¿Creéis que la
santa sede y el papá francisco han
sacrificado los derechos humanos para
ampliar su base de feligreses en China? y
en ese caso ¿os parece que es un
comportamiento ético? Dejadme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y ahora viene la sorpresa que os decía
al principio del vídeo: y es que este
mes de marzo voy a dar tres charlas en
España. Me han invitado a participar en
un evento que se llama el Free Markets
Roadshow y voy a estar dando charlas en la
siguientes ciudades: Sevilla,
Santiago de Compostela y Gijón. Si alguno
de vosotros quiere acercarse encontraréis
más información en los enlaces de la
destrucción y por supuesto no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros al
canal para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado
este vídeo dadle a like  y nos vemos en
el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto.